I decided to do what I do when I was two
years old at two years old you know I
heard the sound of a drum playing in the
village and um and I found my own drum
and just picked it up and started
playing kalibo kalibo vocally Buccola
boo caliber okula the worst song ever
written by white collection but it
actually started a vibe professionally I
started doing what I was doing when I
turned like 13 years old a lot of times
it's surprised people what I do because
they say aren't you a hip hop artist
like how do you know about Bob how do
you know about art blakey how do you
know about crystal girl how do you know
about pink floyd well understand that
you know my background and naturally
what I grew up with was music in the
church and then going to high school I
got introduced to jazz and from the
ninth grade to the 12th grade all I did
was study and play jazz all day so for
me um it's just then I turned 18 years
old and got my first contract with
Atlantic Records big beat at the time
they just released nelson mandela and i
did a record car out of the jungle and
it was dedicated to nelson mandela and i
got with my group the fugees and like
1989 and which was like a high school
band for me and basically with the
Fugees i went on to doing my first CD
the first city was called blended on
reality was me prize and Lauren why did
this thing work it worked because you
had three individuals from three
different styles of music Lauren taught
me about rmb because at the time I was
more into like church music reggae or
rock you know prize was just a rock head
so long come stylistics what's that you
know and then she would play and then I
would automatically learning the first
CD was called blending our reality it
basically tanked and then the second CD
we went to my basement my uncle's
basement me and Jerry one that got
together Lauren and prize and created a
classic that's so basically 22 million
that CD was done inside of a basement so
if you doing music and your basement on
your garage i always say that's the best
place I think that's why you're gonna
get your pets material from or the
bathroom I mean the Wyclef Jean music is
eclectic music weich left represents
eclectic music I've been doing this
music since I was a child and I said I
will refuse for anyone to put me into a
box whenever I want to listen to sell
your cruise I will when I want to here
Pink Floyd I will when I went here Bob
Marley I will I went here nirvana I will
I can and I will I want to listen to jay
z I will biggie smalls do pot and this
is the ipod of a kid today so the Wyclef
Jean music is just eclectic music it's
called good music
I mean my influences range from like
Jimi Hendrix to Bob Marley to Marvin
Gaye and then one of my favorite like
singers you know when I hear him I could
identify with his voice you know a lot a
lot of people be like man how is Johnny
Cash you know what I'm saying I like
Johnny Cash a lot like my dad was a
minister and stuff and just growing up
in the church and I grew up with a lot
of Christian rock and so that's some of
it
I mean the haitian music one of my
favorite bands is called bookman
experience and book my experience
represents the true roots and the
culture of what haitian music is to me
you know that band is a band when I hear
it and they say there's a connection
with Katy and Africa I naturally could
feel that connection it represents not
seen the translation for Garcia is roots
when you listen to that music then you
understand the connection of you know
where the Haitians are from and why the
rhythm sound like that it's it's the
natural music of the country and then
the young generation to listen to a form
of music which is called compound music
and calm pop music is more like there's
bands like jacket music there's bands
like t-vice bands like Cara me that's
sort of like you could say like this bar
Marley and then there is dancehall you
know what I'm saying so that's the best
way to describe it like there's where I
scene and then there's compound so the
younger kids are definitely more into
the compound which is a traditional like
form of like dance music from the
islands created in Haiti which which
definitely has a lot of influence on
what I do
I mean that my music evolved I mean at
this point you know what I'm saying it's
like you know my role model you know I'm
saying like I'm a young Quincy Jones you
know like what i mean by that is that's
my blueprint you know and i feel like my
career is just getting started you know
I'm into a lot of scoring music now I
like the sounds and scores you know I
want to do like big soundtracks from
movies you know I want to like develop
more of the white left side on the sonic
sound and get my own label carnival
house records and start to find great
talent develop it and help expand it